The jogan Experience they're regulating
podcast in Canada oh yeah and I was yeah
I was reading about this about this
build this because I I woke up and you
know we're jet lagged so woke up at
ridiculous time I went on the phone
which you should never do let's be
honest that is a bad way to start the
day it's not good no and then I was
reading about what they're doing it's
terrifying so they want to bring in this
bill whereby they regulate podcast so
what they want to do is every every uh
podcast uh streamer or whatever it is
platform that makes more than $10
million Revenue not profit Revenue has
to register with the Canadian government
they then want them to hand over
information about their content and the
people
listening [__] to their right to their
to the to the government imagine getting
a hold of Alex Jones's email
list probably a bunch of senators on
there yeah oh yeah for sure I mean
imagine yeah and then the government can
get that they're talking right now about
and maybe we we're going to need to fact
check this again because I met I was
reading it this morning but basically
they wanted to promote
Canadian something to do with like
basically what Canadian greatness
whatever it is they they talk about it
and Indigenous Affairs and you're like
oh so they're going to say a number of
things are UNC Canadian and then you can
just silence them look what tro tro
Trudeau did with the truckers yeah yeah
terrifying we just had one of that guys
on to talk about it not just the
truckers but people who donated to the
truckers got their bank accounts closed
yeah yeah well that is wild yeah you got
locked out of all of your money because
you donated to a cause where you didn't
think that people should have to take an
experimental vaccine in order to be able
to work to drive a truck but really
really you get you think that's okay
like that's so not okay the fact that
those people aren't up in arms the whole
country didn't freak out and
demand a [__] change like you can't
have that's dictatorship stuff that's
what that is it's Banana Republic stuff
we do these calls with our top
supporters and we have some in Canada we
have this lady who's been supporting us
for years and she you know she's always
fine and in the middle of this thing she
was like I'm terrified I I'm not going
to be able to eat because they they're
going to shut down my bank account God
right in Canada it's so crazy they think
they could do that if people disagree
with them because that's all they're
doing they're just disagreeing and
they're supporting a protest it should
be and it was a peaceful protest those
people did it the right way they just
parked their trucks and they didn't
block roads off they didn't do anything
[__] up but if you frame it that these
people which is how they were being
framed as racist far right well look
you're giving money to a far right
racist organization you're encouraging
hate well well the government has to
step in we have to step in and we need
to freeze everything because we need to
make everything safe what was this most
recent apology because they accidentally
awarded a Nazi yeah like what what
happened I think so I think zilinsky was
visiting the Canadian Parliament and
they got some guy who was a Ukrainian
inverted commas War veteran turned out
he fought for the for the bad guys in
that one oh my God yeah uh I don't think
they I don't think like zalinski or I I
don't know know yeah he didn't know but
so so imagine you're sitting in
Parliament and everyone's like hey let's
uh do a you know stand up and and give a
round of applause for this war veteran
you're like and then it turns out you're
applauding a Nazi how old is this dude
old he probably doesn't even know I'm
not a good guy I a [__] good guy
maybe he's like tricked himself that he
wasn't a na
imagine